this is a very exciting piece of
research and
we're well aware that we need to collect
information
on whether we can mix vaccine schedules
those are advised to have the same
second vaccine as as the first faction
at the moment
there is promising uh experimental
evidence that actually
the mixing of vaccines actually might
give you a better and longer term of
term protection and so we're very very
interested in the results of this study
and of course
going along the line we're going to have
many many more vaccines
and many many more potential
combinations of vaccines so it's going
to be really important that we see this
data when it comes out
and make some policy decisions about who
is going to receive which vaccines there
are also potential supply benefits
aren't there if you've got the 12-week
gap
and somebody has had a fisa vaccine for
example
you've got to be able to guarantee
you've got enough stocks of that ready
to give the second dose at this point if
you can mix
depending on what you've got the most of
at that time that would be an advantage
wouldn't it
probably a huge advantage yes i mean our
advice at the moment is that it's much
better to have a second dose of a
different vaccine than no
back second dose at all but that is not
based on any evidence some of the
theoretical evidence which we know from
other vaccines such as
hepatitis b ebola vaccine that you can
actually mix vaccine schedules but but
actually
getting some hard scientific data on
this will be
really important in guiding our policy
decision making in the future but are
you confident
that without getting that data at this
stage
based on what we know so far we will
have the right doses to be able to give
people the second
dose of the vaccine they've already had
well it's our preferred
uh steer on jcpi that you do have that
same second dose of vaccine as you had
the first
um so these are all down to supply
issues really which is outside the
jcbi's remits but at the moment our
clear steer is to have the same
second doses first but we do understand
in exceptional circumstances where this
isn't possible
our guidance is still that it's better
to have a second dose
another vaccine than no vaccine
at the moment the focus is on delivering
first doses
as we head towards at the end of march
beginning of april we'll start to see
that 12-week window opening up for the
second doses
for at the first cohorts what is the
impact of those second doses
going to have on the rate of delivery of
vaccines the number of people
new people we're seeing being vaccinated
well clearly our part is to get as many
people vaccinated as quickly as possible
one that one of the things that the
government have been very good at i
think is increasing the capacity of
vaccinators
so with mass vaccination science with
hospital hubs with a fantastic
primary care network which we've got
throughout the country
we're really up to the challenge of
vaccinating both first and second doses
and and you know this is going to be
incredibly important
i mean i think actually i believe that
the rate limiting factor is going to be
supply
rather than vaccinators because i think
the capacity for vaccinations
is very large in this country and very
impressive
yeah i mean you're a gp as well you've
also been involved in vaccinating people
and from your experience doing that
at the moment it does seem does it not
that the the limiting factor is the
supply
of vaccines uh the health care workers
the frontline workers are there ready to
vaccinate
if they're given the supply yeah you're
absolutely right in our own practice
we have the uh capacity to deliver more
than a thousand vaccines per week
and we're not getting that amount of
supply at the moment so
because we've done so well it's rightly
been
the supply which is limited has rightly
been devolved to parts of the country
and areas that have have had less
success in
uh vaccinating a percentage of their
their vulnerable population
so i fully appreciate that so hence my
my strong view that it's not vaccinating
capacity that's the issue it's supply
but of course
it's difficult i mean these these these
uh vaccines are very difficult to
manufacture they have to go through all
sorts of quality control the
distribution chain is difficult
involves a very clear cold chain
particularly for the fisa vaccine which
has to be delivered at
at very very low temperatures minus 70.
so so this isn't easy but we're doing
incredibly well
in our country we've you know to receive
to
bypass the the 10 million mark
is is an extraordinary achievement a
national achievement
and i have every confidence that we're
going to press on ahead
and continue with this excellent results
that we're getting at the moment
but if we do run into supply issues with
for example
pfizer you would advocate for people
getting an astrazeneca vaccine rather
than
nothing at all so we could see a
situation where we have
mixed doses before the findings of this
trial i mean it's certainly possible but
i think i think everybody's making a
huge effort to try and get those
second doses exactly the same as the
first doses so there's
a lot of work going on behind the scenes
to uh try and marry this up
it may not be perfect but but it will be
try we will try our best
to make sure that people receive the
same vaccine type the second dose
as they have done for the first days the
government confident we are on
schedule to have administered vaccines
to the first four priority groups by
mid-february then move on to groups five
to nine
at what point do you envisage all over
fifties
having been vaccinated and then uh the
rest of the
adult population some reports all adults
could be fully vaccinated by august is
that realistic
well i i think we're doing so well the
these um months and targets that are
are are rooted are quite possible but
i i wouldn't like to put any predictions
on the exact dates by which we'll do
this
all i can do is reassure the public that
we'll do this as quickly
as efficiently and as safely as possible
and and rest assured that jcp are
absolutely
committed at the moment to our first
nine priority groups
so once we've reached the they've gone
through the first four priority groups
we still want to go through those next
five priority groups
from the age of 50 onwards because i
understand that there are many many
people
uh in 50 to 70 year old age group that
are very sick in hospital at the moment
and on itu facilities so we don't want
to lose sight
of the fact that this illness is
particularly attacks
people older people and age is a huge
risk factor and
and just because we've got down to the
70 age group
we should be pushing ahead to try and
get all those vaccinated from 15 and
above
so then no plans at this stage to start
vaccinating
teachers when we move into the next
groups five to nine
and of course all teachers that that fit
into
the age group of 50 or above or have an
underlying illness will be vaccinated
after that phase two it is going to be
partly a
decision about a clinical need but
partly a political decision about
which groups um key workers and such
are going to be vaccinated so so there's
going to be a number of different
elements to phase two
but from jcpr we're still very clear
that we
we understand about um those are the
risk of disease
those are the deprived populations those
ethnic minority groups that we need to
reach out to
and we will be pushing that very hard
whether we go along the key worker
approach depends on the input from our
bodies and within ours
what do you make of the suggestion that
we had the ons figures this week one in
seven
people had had the virus by mid-january
some suggestion that those who've had a
previous infection of coronavirus and
have antibodies could be just given
one dose of the vaccine is that
something that the jc
vi would back well theoretically
that that's not a bad idea but of course
practically it's quite a difficult thing
to do
because you would have to demonstrate
that the person had antibodies
before they got the vaccine which could
then act as a booster dose
following their natural infections so
practically this might be quite
difficult to do
theoretically it's not a silly idea but
it's one that we will
discuss on jcpi in detail and
formulate some clear policy advice
around
just one very brief final thought we've
had a little bit more information from
astrazeneca
this week are you still comfortable with
that 12-week gap between doses
well the astrazeneca data looks really
fabulous actually i mean it
does seem to suggest that not only does
the first ghost give you substantial
protection
but a delay in the second dose to 12
weeks gives you a better and longer term
protection
so so this this was all very positive
evidence
um to uh to acknowledge that our
strategy that we've
boldly outlined is probably the correct
strategy not only for the population but
might be
the correct strategy for that individual
in terms of getting longer and better
term protection
the other exciting thing about the
astrazeneca data was the
the um the data which suggests that
uh two-thirds of people that had the
vaccine don't transmit
and that's going to be hugely important
in trying to contain
the epidemic that we're in professor
anthony hardin
thank you very much indeed